my name is sami al-sheikh i'm doing
research in csail on using radar
signatures for object classif
classification
why radar
radar can have the potential to reveal
information about objects that usual
image and video signal processing may
lack like texture and material
information also recently
engineers have developed a radar that is
works at a very high frequency and fits
on a chip
so we'd like to leverage this because
it's possible it will become more
ubiquitous and more portable in the
coming years
using radar in an unknown environment is
a highly unconstrained problem so we
decided to go with a machine learning
approach namely neural nets we've
already shown that with this approach we
can distinguish materially different
objects
that are the same shape
we can also additionally understand
which direction they're facing so this
is very promising future work should
check how robust our system is to
orientation of the radar and translation
of the object